my dad always told me that
you only get one name
so invest in it accordingly
and i always thought about that i
thought it was a really good line just
like you only get one name like you can
change your companies you can go
bankrupt but like your name stays with
you yeah and so
that can either be an asset or it can be
a liability
well i usually ask my guest how did you
get this job so
i was a management consultant
right out of college i did
space cyber intelligence for the
military which was
sounds much cooler than it really was
but i had a top secret clearance it
sounded really good at dinner parties
and just about only that
um and you know one day i looked out for
my balcony because i had a really nice
place because i could afford it at the
time um and i was like is this it and i
was you know in my young 20s you know at
that point i had done everything that i
think i was supposed to do so i was you
know i did well in school i you know was
president of all the clubs you know
graduated in three years got the good
job um
and i realized that it was i was living
you know a life for me that my father
wanted me to live and so
that was kind of you know i went i i
faltered back and forth for probably a
period of six months um
of really not wanting this to be my life
but not wanting to let my dad down and
so at some point the the thing that kind
of pushed me over the edge was i can
either you know die to myself or i can
die to my father and at the end of the
day you know i have to survive so i will
if i if i make this decision and he no
longer wants to be my dad then i can
accept that wow was that extreme then
yes say more about that are you an only
child yeah so only child raised by a
single father um middle eastern um he
was born in iran
and um you know i everything in my life
up until that point was really just to
make him proud so i it was very much a
seeking approval seeking validation kind
of drive at that point in my life and so
the idea of disappointing him or not
getting his approval felt like death and
at that point i was actually
contemplating not living you have
watched some of my youtube stuff
mortality has been the single biggest
driver and the biggest decisions that
i've made in my life and it has become a
more routine
process for decision making for me in
general
because i think it provides clarity and
it provides context
to most of the decisions we have which
the vast majority of them don't matter
which is helpful
in and of themselves and then you know
beyond that it helps me make the
decisions that i think removes everyone
else from the playbook because if you if
you study subjective well-being and how
people perceive how they're doing in
their own lives it looks like a smiley
face so seven-year-olds think they're
killing life
and then it drops dramatically between
20 and 30. and then there's still a
little bit more of a dip right around 45
that's like when people are their true
they hate life the most
and then and then it kind of slowly get
goes up to like 55 60 and then it shoots
right back up again when people see that
they're going to die and that life is
short and that they can make the
decisions without worrying about the
ramifications of other people and some
of the people they're worried about are
also dead and so it was using that
context for that biggest decision that's
been duplicated many times in my life
since then because if i have a good
decision-making algorithm i try and
reuse it as many times as i can let's
unpack it for the audience a little bit
so you know when we're seven
we don't have a care in the world
uh the artist or the whatever we want to
be has not been beaten out of us yet uh
no one's told us that we are not what we
think we are we're still popping
wheelies and climbing trees and falling
out and that's okay
and then you get to your 20s and 30s and
the rubber hits the road a little bit
and if you've made money i guess and if
that's your sign of success then you're
okay but if not
you're kind of hosed
then in your 40s i'm guessing
uh you start to have more life
experience
50s maybe you start caring less what
people think
and then um and then you fast forward
all the way to maybe near death
and then you really get to a point where
you don't care what anyone says and you
really boil it down to what's important
and probably i'm guessing that's
love relationships
uh legacy
and then you just like peace out i think
for most people yes
for me specifically the legacy piece
less so um but i think for most people
yes
and why is the legacy piece less
important um
more so and i whenever i get into this
topic i think a lot of like some people
get sensitive about it and so i just
like to put the disclaimer like this is
not me judging your beliefs and me
stating my beliefs is in no way yeah a
judgment on anywhere else um but if you
just look at expanding the time horizon
over a much longer period of time if you
look at it in ten thousand years or a
hundred thousand years or a million
years right the easy way to test this is
to go backwards right which is do you
know your great great great great great
great grandfather probably not and then
if you look at it from a how much has
somebody achieved standpoint um i happen
to be in an interesting situation where
my great great grandfather was in the
ruling class in iran
and he had 400 children so he was
literally you know like ruled and had a
lot of wealth he had a lot of wives to
create 400 children right and i actually
still can't remember his name because my
dad told me one time and i can't
remember it and i've never seen any of
the quote legacy that i'm sure he felt
like he was leaving and so if that was
that level of success
and legacy
and only four or five generations later
i don't even remember the man's name nor
do i have any piece of that legacy yeah
it seems a little bit irrelevant when
the revolution happened in iran
we talk about legacy
lands buildings houses bank accounts
government says those are ours now
that's it there's your legacy
gone
that's why i'm like and people were like
i want to build a legacy i'm like u.s
might not even be the superpower in 500
years
your kids your kids might be in in
bangladesh who knows india might be the
hot spot 500. no one knows right and i
think in a long enough time verizon
we're all screwed and i think in some
ways people find that incredibly
disheartening but an equal opposite is
you can't find it both disheartening and
also not freeing because all of the
decisions that we're making that are not
for ourselves or what or are are subject
to change that we feel pressure from
whether that be society societal i'll
put quotes there because that's a big
word um or family friends expectations
that we perceive other people to have of
us
if you can if you can just relinquish
all of those chains i think it's
incredibly freeing and um i choose to
live that way that advice is good
because it helps us live in the moment
because
you know even if you believe in
something after that's still in the
future
yeah and there's a question mark because
no one actually knows with you know with
knowledge what happens or if something
happens so you might as well live in the
present make the best of it yeah an
interesting one um that i thought
through around that was um a lot of us
not a lot of us all of us have 100
experience uh not being alive
right before we were born we were not
alive and so we know what that was like
there was nothing um that we can
recollect and so i would imagine that
that's the closest experience that we
can have to not being live yet again
which to me is not that frightening yeah
and it is freeing you're right because
it's it's both uh humbling to know that
you don't matter in the grand scheme of
things but at the same time you matter
infinitely
if you just focus on the present
and the the mark that you're going to
leave here and now i i contemplated i
had to die to my father died of myself
and i realized that i i would rather die
to him
which pretty much ended up happening and
so my fears were relatively justified he
was not in support of the things that i
wanted to do i ended up quitting that
job sold everything i had packed my car
went to california because that's what i
thought the land of fitness opportunity
was because that was the only thing i
really enjoyed mentored under a guy for
a few months to try and at least learn
the ropes started my first facility
slept on the floor for the first nine
months which was a very terrible
experience for me and time stamped the
age for me now i was
23.
so you graduated early you got that
dream job and then you bailed yeah two
years and that was really at the time
and all of this kind of it was at the a
splitting point where i had done two
years and the kind of career path
traditionally is like two to four years
of
management consulting and then you go
back to an ivy league for your gmat and
then from there you go into you know you
can you can go do investment banking you
can do private equity you can do you
know some of the bigger white collar
jobs but um
it was i just didn't i didn't want more
of what i had um
and so
i thought that i would have a better
shot taking 200 000 in two years which
is what the you know economic equivalent
of what the degree was and starting
something on my own i figured i would
learn more in the first two years and
with that money and maybe even have a
business by the end of that period of
time that made an equivalent amount of
money compared to what i would have had
as a job offer but how did you
what signals did you get i mean you're
saying like i wasn't feeling it but like
where was your motivation because i see
you as this hustler this go-get is all
about gobbling up new opportunities it
transcends beyond that now but like at
first it sounds like you were just all
about the go get but how did you know i
mean at first i was driven by fear
okay it was all fear fear of failure
feel of disappointment fear of other
people's judgment right
what did your dad end up saying did he
say
good luck with you no he thought he was
stupid though i was wasting my life yeah
and wasted a degree that he'd spent
money on and yeah wasted a good job
opportunity that he had set up for me
all these things right
in his defense
did he immigrate here yeah okay so in
his defense 100 right
and i just want to tell the audience so
that they're not like but
it's like you know if you have justified
in saying that yeah if you escape from a
country where there's trauma
and impending danger
then your son squanders an opportunity
you might get a little anxious about
that 100 i mean my dad came here with a
thousand dollars
you know a medical degree yeah and then
built every didn't even speak english
right i think what he did was harder
than what i've done
like i got to i got to stand on his
shoulders okay you know in huawei
i mean i speak english
you know like just the basics like i
speak english i went to a good school
just all the support infrastructure
known and unknown that was around me
yeah to you know to be successful yeah i
think it's healthy to recognize your
privilege yeah but at the same time you
know it came with lots of baggage too
and so you had signals which were mainly
fear-based yeah and i i mean the biggest
thing that made the decision for me i
would say i had the logical decision and
then i had the emotional decision the
emotional decision was
um
i could i don't want to do this
this is not the life i want to lead um i
am not happy doing this every day i
would prefer to not be alive if this is
what my life will be continuously if i
would prefer to not be alive then that
kind of opens up my decision calculus
and what was it i'm trying to put my
finger on what what was it that made you
happy was it just the freedom to do what
you want i didn't know what made me
happy i knew it was not making me happy
okay yeah so i think that's another
important lesson too if i can just
extract them you know i'm sure a lot of
people watching they feel the same kind
of family pressure um they want to be
what other people expect them to be if
you know if that's
who you are and that's totally normal um
but we should always remember
the context in which that advice is
given could be given through the lens of
a certain lifestyle a certain time frame
but like i think that's a thing
whether you're young or middle age
you're trying to figure out what you
want to be when you grow up you're
trying to have it all figured out yeah
because we don't seems like we don't
like
uncertainty but i think your message if
i'm hearing you is
sometimes you have to try it on for size
to see if it fits or not
and you get it on you're like well i
thought that dream job was going to be
like perfect but turns out you know
it's tight in the crotch
you know it's like
i i need something different mm-hmm and
i think giving yourself permission to do
that and it was a side to what you were
saying about my dad like
education saved his life like he was
only able to leave the country because
he was educated and so there's very deep
roots there and i can appreciate that
but for this context or for my life it
just wasn't appropriate right and when
we did come to terms later
um the only time he's ever apologized to
me in my life and said but to be fair in
my time i would have been right
oh absolutely and he would have been
it's just not the same time yeah
absolutely it wasn't that it was
inappropriate it was just out of context
and it didn't necessarily translate to
this new life
i love the saying you know in our 20s
we're concerned about what everyone
thinks about us in our 40s we don't care
what anyone thinks about us and in our
60s we realized that no one was thinking
about us to begin with right and i just
i just feel like that's i mean who else
have you thought about today besides
yourself probably not i mean you have
your kids which is an extension of
yourself but you know i feel like yeah
not a lot and so most people are like
that and you know
a lot of it like we have a lot more
leeway than i think we give ourselves
credit for and i think the more that i
have now you know i'll say accomplished
with quotes in in material success the
more i am excited about the things that
i can do and that was why the opening of
the book was like there are no rules
and it just took me a very long time to
realize that and i continued to unlearn
rules that i thought existed you know as
i continue to you know go on this
journey yeah i love that idea of
unlearning i think we all just try and
go back to being like we were when we
were children just because when you're a
child you're purely present right you're
just present in the moment and i i don't
like the word happy very much i prefer
using joy because you can be you can
mourn joyfully
right because it's it's a it's a it's
internal rather than
happiness which i feel is more like
happenstance it's more from external and
so um you know what are the things that
bring me joy were the things that i find
you know to find joy in um and i think
for anyone who's listening it's a much
harder question to answer what are the
things that bring me joy
than
answering the question what are the
things i hate
and it's easier to correct those first
you're like well i hate my job and i
hate my relationship and i hate the city
okay those are all very changeable and a
lot of times you get there by by
inversion well if i wanted to destroy my
life i wanted to have the worst life
possible what would i do and then taking
all those things that you would do to
really destroy your life and make your
life miserable and then reverse them
it's a much easier way to solve the
positive psychology equation in my
opinion yeah i love that and i'm
remembering this this picasso quote
which is i think he said
everyone is born an artist yeah right
and then eventually we
you know
get convinced that we're not yeah and we
have to really just strip away and get
you know get back to basics